catalytic converter thefts are on the
rise here in las vegas it seems like
every other week we're talking about yet
another incident and tonight orco mana
introduces us to two men now in dire
need after theirs was stolen and also
explains what thieves might be doing
with these stolen parts
we're seeing it more and more here in
las vegas these climbing under cars to
steal catalytic converters and the
latest victims are two disabled veterans
james wayne needed to go to the grocery
store wednesday so he used his motorized
chair to get from his apartment to his
kia sportage i got in the car and i got
this big rumble sound and i thought it
was going to blow up
the deafening noise led james to check
under his car where he saw a deep cut
his catalytic converter had been sawed
off and stolen
james turns 80 years old next month he
drives himself and his 60 year old
roommate chris around town both are
veterans now struggling due to
disabilities and without use of their
car they feel stuck we're sitting here
we can't go to the store we can't go to
the doctor you know and
we're homebound again it'll cost around
25 hundred dollars to replace their
catalytic converter a steep price for
two men on a fixed income we don't have
the money to be able to go out and and
replace this item and it took away our
transportation we're really in a poor
situation we run into the problem car
expert sarah mark says a big driving
force behind catalytic converter thefts
is that their metal components are very
valuable sometimes worth nearly 600
dollars per converter the thieves are
stealing them selling them to recyclers
who will hope to reclaim that medal
and put it back into the market mark
says metal recyclers check serial
numbers and ids but those are not
foolproof their numbers would put a stop
to it very quickly that's for sure
as chris and james process how someone
could do this to them you just hurt
people
and you don't realize how you heard them
they're deciding what to do next now i
got 2500 dollars i gotta
figure out some way to get orco mana
live local now